i've come together of commerce charity
to help those people in afghanistan who
are poor on top of that they've been hit
by an earthquake please go to the link
and donate whatever you can for the sake
of allah
yes you're thinking brother ali once
again look at you free mixing calm down
relax yourself i'm here with my wife my
wife called some of the sisters and
we're doing a social experiment now if
you guys remember i came to stratford
four years ago it was scorching heat and
i thought to myself all these sisters
were in the cab hijab even those who are
wearing turban or even those who don't
wear the hijab but they are taking
little steps to wear the hijab they need
some encouragement especially from us
prophet so i did the experiment where i
showed them my phone and it had this
message on today i'm here with our
sisters may allah bless them inshallah
where we're go i'll be holding the
plaque out this time and they will be
giving out these sweets and these cards
in sha allah to encourage our sisters
who are wearing the hijab in this hot
weather let's see how they react we'll
see you guys soon
[Music]
and seeing like other muslim girls
wearing hijab and abaya just encourages
us to do the same how do you feel about
receiving this gift um it's very
encouraging and yeah i'm pleased
i felt amazing honestly it feels good it
feels rewarding at the end of the day
because you're going through all this
struggle but it's gonna like it's gonna
be worth it at the end we're proud of
you at the end of the day you know you
know sometimes your age sometimes you
get influenced by social pressure beauty
even sometimes you know hijabi tutorials
to take their hijabs off does that put
pressure on you like and if it does
these kind of things like seeing this
today did it make you feel like you know
what at least we have you know visit
coach sisters or like brothers in islam
that encourages us does it give you that
bit of encouragement
yeah i mean like sometimes like i do
kind of like feel pressured like seeing
like others like taking their hijab off
and they look really pretty without it
but then like some others influence you
into like wearing gear and they
compliment you and they like it suits
you more and then like they let you know
that oh you're not doing it for others
you're doing it for like a lot so okay
guys so subhanallah i just saw my wife
uh approaching the sister and gave her a
sweet and they hugged each other and i
was probably one of my wife's friends
what made you hug her so you know when
she gave me this little gift she said
like she was telling me thank you for
being modest in this heat and it's like
i'm doing it for the sake of my religion
it wasn't like something i was doing i
was like you know it is kind of our
choice but i just felt grateful for
being appreciated you know do you think
that it's important for brothers and
muslim men to encourage their fellow
like be their daughters be their sisters
do you think it plays a role and
strengths the sisters if it was my dad
and my brother you know encouraging me
about my team and saying like i'm proud
of you i know it's hot like sometimes
you want to get in the car my dad's like
trying to turn the ac on i know you're
home and it makes you feel you know like
it makes you happy and yeah it makes you
so the reason we're doing the social
experiment is to call you guys to
patients
[Music]
how does it make you feel like you know
the sister's giving this reminder
because it's been really hot for the
past couple of days i know i think it's
really good and happily i see you in a
place like this it's really really good
because obviously there's so much people
you've got all the cultures there you've
got people from everywhere to see you
doing something like this it's just
really good it's more important like for
example that brothers encourage sisters
definitely yeah definitely yeah yeah do
you feel when you when you came past you
looked at the sign i saw that and from
the stairs i was very excited i said
masha allah what do you know you like
about it what is it what does it make
you feel like inside when you come down
how do you see happiness
happiness
that you know you know you're doing a
great job you're spreading the dawah
masha allah encouraging the sisters
alhamdulillah
i'm going to start wearing my hedgehog
one time in year 7 like very soon how
did you feel my darling good valley
you take care and enjoy your sweets
so her sister stopped you and said you
answered her dua literally it was like
subhanallah like i went up to her she
said what's this and i said just
something here to say you know
alhamdulillah encouragement for your you
know hijab in this heat you know and
then she said subhanallah this is a door
that's been answered you are the answer
to my daughter
look at that i feel like because of
social media you see like so many people
taking off their hijab and then like it
kind of influences you but then by
seeing things like this like you're
reminded that like you're not living for
this dunya like it's all about the
afterlife and what's going to happen
don't ever forget that you're actually
wearing the eye of the quran on your
head literally yeah so may allah
preserve you guys keep you patient it
gets hot but never ever think that your
efforts are going to go to waste never
think that on the day of judgement when
you're putting this effort in and
somebody who's not is going to be in the
same level it's not so i just wanted to
give that inshallah with the sisters
inshallah basically any last words
allah says remind foreign benefits of
believer this is how important and
profound it is for us to give these
little reminders because they have such
huge impacts
when did you start with the hijab
yeah three marshall how was it
it was really fun and i started wearing
it more and now i'm just wearing it
every day but you think brothers like me
and many brothers we should be
encouraging sisters more yes yeah
messages alhamdulillah it's what we
should do for each other is what we owe
each other as muslims i was eight when i
started to wear the hijab my parents
were born and raised in the north which
is predominantly muslim but my father
was the main reason why we started to
wear the hijab he loved it he spoke
about it in so many ways like have you
struggled like with the heat and
everything over the last couple of days
to be honest yeah this the heat has been
his struggle but you know it's all about
intention like you know it's for allah
so so guys we did the experiment and
subhanallah it was amazing there was
very good feedback people were reading
it encouraged even people came some
sisters came and said you know you guys
actually answered my door i want to
thank my wife may allah bless her for
making this happen as well sister aisha
for spending endless the whole night
making the series and putting it
together sister neymar for coming and
encouraging people subhanallah giving
the cards and sister nyla who'd done the
camera work and was giving out the
cosmic every single one of you guys for
doing this inshallah um how did you guys
find it in a nutshell it was you know
what it was really like fulfilling for
my heart that we were able to touch so
many sisters i actually met a sister on
the train on the way up and she had been
struggling with hijab she was wearing a
turban and she said subhanallah today i
came out in the full hijab and this card
i gave her some sweets as well she said
this really encouraged me it's like a
last sent you to me but it's just been
such an amazing opportunity thank you to
zachary to ali and his wife for bringing
us involved in this because it increases
our iman as well and it increases our
love for the hijab as well that you know
we're doing this for the sake of allah
we've had so many reminders from sisters
today as well it's been it's been
amazing alhamdulillah i'm really happy
i think the sister who said that we've
been an uh an answer to her was really
like to find out i think the most
humbling thing for me you know and when
some of the young sisters they're 14
and that's exactly what we did today
calling them the truth and calling them
to be patient inshallah you don't need
to speak maybe you can give two thumbs
up how do you feel she's happy okay
we're all happy as a brother what i
would say is if you are have a daughter
brothers fathers uncles siblings
encourage them well it's so important
that they see that at the home inshallah
till next time brother sisters may allah
bless you guys inshallah and brother
skew maybe you can do the same
experiment in new york we'll see you
guys later may allah bless every single
one of you guys assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh